so let's talk about the best way to make up the
damage after you consume refined carbohydrates
i'm talking about the breads the pasta the
cereals the biscuits the waffles the pancakes
those refined carbohydrates not that you would
ever get into those refined carbohydrates but
if you know someone who is consuming those you
might want to send on this video so they can then
make up the damage first question is what is
the damage of consuming refined carbohydrates
well you're cramming a tremendous amount of
fuel into the machine into the mitochondria
and it's going to be overloaded with electrons
and other things okay now at the same time
because those carbohydrates are refined that
means you don't get the benefit of antioxidants
and nutrients that are normally
supposed to protect against this
oxidation and free radical damage but now what
happens is the mitochondria because it can't
utilize this fuel there's a lot of byproducts that
occur uh in the form of oxidants and free radicals
and that is what causes the collateral damage the
microvascular inflammation that targets the retina
of the eye the kidney the heart specifically
the inside of the arteries as well as your brain
and the nerves now that you know what the
damage is what can we do to make up the damage
well antioxidants all right most of the
antioxidants that you're going to get
come from plant source but you can also get them
from fish and seafood because omega-3 fatty acids
can act as an antioxidant not to mention other
things like selenium and even organ meats have
significant antioxidants in heart meat you
have very high levels of coenzyme q10 in fact
10 times that of tocopherols which is part
of the vitamin e complex all right secondly
you do not want to get your antioxidants
from synthetic vitamins specifically
synthetic antioxidants you may or may not
know this but the majority probably 99.9
of all the vitamins sold you know like
the vitamin a vitamin e vitamin c are made
synthetically okay you do not want to get your
antioxidants from those so-called nutrients why
because the studies that demonstrate antioxidants
actually increase your mortality are done with
those synthetic antioxidants not from actual food
antioxidants so anytime you take vitamins and you
want to get antioxidants make sure they're a
food concentrate or a natural plant-based type
vitamin but not the synthetic versions if you want
more information on that i put a link down below
ideally you should get your antioxidants from
salad vegetables cruciferous and a lot of herbs
and even green tea is a great thing to do and
at the same time you want to avoid omega-6 oils
grains and animals who eat grains by the
way because it's high in omega 6 which is
inflammatory ice cream because you have you're
combining fat with sugar which is even worse than
consuming sugar chips which is fat and carbs not
a good combination creates a lot of inflammation
and then also when you combine like protein with
sugar like barbecued ribs that type of thing
not a good combination because all that increases
inflammation and free radical damage and not good
so when someone consumes refined carbohydrates we
want to counter some of that damage by consuming
at the same time antioxidant type foods so
after you consume a huge bowl of ice cream and
a loaf of bread followed up with a huge bowl of
salad and that will reduce the damage hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone is focused on
this over here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening your
immune system that's what's missing this course
will show you how to bulletproof yourself and so
you can tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own immune
system i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today